um okay here we go
congresswoman susie lee thank you so
much for joining us and
my first question um is about some
endorsements
maybe unexpected like the review journal
uh chamber of commerce usually going
republican but they endorsed you what do
you want to say about that
well listen i am proud to have those
endorsements and i think it's a
reflection of the work that i've done in
congress since i've been there for two
years of really trying to work
uh with both parties across the aisle in
a bipartisan manner
to get things done that are so important
to nevada families and
i think there's a recognition that i'm
putting politics aside
and trying to get progress and solve
problems
as you know i joined the problem solvers
caucus which is a caucus of 25 democrats
and 25 republicans when i first came to
congress
and really that was my commitment to the
constituents of congressional district
three
that they actually want to see a member
of congress who's going to
try to outreach and build relationships
with members of both parties because as
we know this is such a polarized time
in this country and what i hear from my
constituents is they just want to see
that we're actually
getting together having those tough
conversations because everything isn't
black and white
and a lot of these issues do require a
lot of back and forth and compromise
in policy discussions and so you need to
have someone
who's committed to doing that and i
think that that was both of those
endorsements
our recognition that that's the type of
leadership i bring to this sea
you mentioned the problem solvers caucus
what would you say is your biggest
bipartisan achievement
well listen i mean we've passed uh i
think the biggest thing that the problem
solvers
caucus has done was our break the
gridlock package
which really was to address some of the
rules that have prevented uh
things from coming to the floor of the
house so for instance we
got a rule passed that if you get us
co-sponsorship of 290 members of
congress
it has to be bipartisan at that point
that it has to come to the floor of the
house for a vote
and you know you think about it there
have been many
pieces of legislation that have had uh
wide support across this country
that have been prevented from even
getting their time
in congress by the leadership and so
that's it that's a big accomplishment of
this and then
uh probably the biggest thing is as you
know
the democrats in the house we passed the
heroes act
uh over five months ago it had been
sitting on mitch mcconnell's desk
there was really no movement about it it
was a stalemate
about a month ago we came together the
problem solvers caucus really
it was just all of us rank and file
members and said
how can we get these negotiations moving
again because as you know especially
here
in southern nevada we have so many
families that are struggling that are
worried about paying rent
putting food on their table and so we
got together
and put together our own package of
guidelines
and it was instrumental in restarting
the negotiations that are happening
right now
so even the president even tweeted out a
couple days ago
that it's the problem solvers uh package
that he's looking
at as a compromise so i think it's you
know really taking
on us having that tough conversation us
looking at all the different issues and
trying to find out
what is it that we can get pat like what
is it we can get done because
ultimately we have to get a third
stimulus package passed and it cannot
wait until after the election and so
we've been
instrumental in forcing and pushing and
condoling
our leadership to get this package
passed
and since it is stalled should
it be passed piece by piece then
uh listen i you know i'm a proponent of
looking at comprehensive because who
you what are we how are we going to make
those trade-offs that you know we
obviously we want the aviation industry
uh
to succeed and not go under but also
here in nevada we have so many small
business owners
restaurant owners our live entertainment
you know and so to me i think it's all a
comprehensive package we have to look at
you know extending unemployment benefits
look at
testing and tracing and so i'd like to
see it come together as a comprehensive
package
if it just can't come together as a
comprehensive package though
could you maybe list i know you said
everything is important but could you
maybe list
top three priorities in your opinion
uh you know the biggest priority for me
is obviously state and local funding
um you know we have seen in nevada about
a quarter of our state budget has a hole
in it because of this
pandemic and basically we have already
given state and local funding but a lot
of it was
dedicated towards expenses that were
related to covid19 and so
uh looking at um assistance to states
that will help them when they've seen a
reduction of
revenue as we're seeing here in southern
nevada
and i believe listen we're not going to
get past the economic fallout
of this virus until we get past the
public health crisis
so i believe that this 75 billion
dollars or additional funding
not just funding for a testing and
tracing strategy
but also a strategy and making sure it's
one that we can move
to allow our schools to open allow
our bigger convention spaces to open etc
if we had
rapid testing if we were able to
concentrate that testing
in in a way that and i know that there's
several businesses here who are taking
it upon themselves
but just think about how incredibly
powerful
that would be if the federal government
could take a leadership
in that and um and then you know the
extension of the ppp program
that's been incredibly important to our
state we've had over
close to 45 000 businesses uh use those
resources over a half a million jobs
um you know i mean the list goes on
unemployment extended unemployment
benefits another uh
stimulus check i just feel that we had
done
such incredible bipartisan work with the
families first act
and then the cares bill and now it's
really when
you know we are seeing people they that
are on the precipice
and we need to get that additional aid
there
you know housing and rental assistance
as well is so important too
um you have a background in education
what is the solution in the middle of a
pandemic
should students be back in the classroom
well first of all i think that's our
ultimate goal i'm we know
that distance learning uh is not
the is not the preferred outcome here we
want to get students back in the
classroom safely
um you know i think again to me this all
comes back with
what are we doing to stop the community
spread
what are we doing to make sure that
we're getting the incidents of
covet 19 down in our community
protecting you know again we know that
students or young kids can be carriers
can become they might not get as sick
but then they go home to families where
family members might have a comorbidity
or another pre-existing conditions or
teachers may have it
and so to me it's really measuring what
we're doing to stop the community spread
uh but also how we can keep people safe
and ultimately it comes to funding
when you think about it if we could you
know even if we did a hybrid model
where kids went for two days on two days
out that's increased
transportation it's increased staffing
all of that takes additional funding
additional ppe even if you were to do
additional testing which i think is so
important
you know where we have seen schools that
have opened and have been
relatively successful they've been able
to identify
uh spread before it got out of hand and
isolated and that's going to be really
important but again all of that requires
funding and that's why the state and
local funding is so incredibly important
as a part of the heroes 2.0 act anything
um you'd like to add
about that additional challenge
for parents of students with special
needs
with the distance learning
yeah i listen i mean we have seen our
most vulnerable
students have been falling further and
further behind whether it is
students who are living in poverty who
didn't have access to
either internet or the devices but also
our special needs because they require
that additional touch point they require
the additional resources
and how are we delivering that you know
online
is important you know that's been an
important issue that i've been an
advocate for
uh i was i introduced the bill protect
our
uh students act which is basically uh
i'm sorry keep our pact act which is
basically to fully fund
idea and title one uh traditionally the
federal government has never given
those exact resources to our state it
would mean about 400 million dollars a
year
for our state funding if we as a federal
government
fully funded uh those resources and so
again to me a lot of this comes down to
making sure we're continuing to fight
uh for the necessary resources we need
um but also you know we all have to work
together
to stop the spread of this virus and we
know
that the economic fallout our fallout
for our
families who are you know having to
teach their students at home
um we can beat this and literally we
have the
we have the resources at our fingertips
it's called a mask
and if people would simply just wear
that
and social distance not be in large
groups but
to me it's so important especially for
our special ed students to get back into
the classroom
uh joe biden joe biden finally said he
is not
a fan of court hacking what are your
thoughts
listen i you know my thoughts are
right now we are faced with the
most major crisis
at least in my lifetime in this country
this pandemic
families are on the brink of collapse
businesses
are on the brink of bankruptcy and
this administration is choosing to rush
through
supreme court hearings at this point
looking at basically being able to
place a justice on the court just in
time
for the supreme court hearing on the
affordable care act
which would take away protections for
pre-existing conditions from millions of
americans
so i find it that right now
as i've said before i am a one issue
congresswoman at this point i think the
biggest issue facing congress right now
is making sure we get another package
past the finish line
onto the president's desk and signed
moving on to dan rodimer um
one of his attack ads claims
that you are nancy pelosi's puppet
what do you want to say about that uh
dan rhodeimer is taking a book out of
the republican party playbook
and basically i think that my
endorsements speak for themselves the
review journal
the chamber of commerce i've been ranked
by the lugar center which ranks
uh members based on their bipartisanship
as one of the most bipartisan
members of congress uh and so i think
it's a false attack
but it's basically one that is being
played all across this country
um by my on you know by republicans who
are
uh going after seats held by democrats
and
um you know but then you have to look at
what road eimer's
uh what rhode eimer's record is
and basically he's running on a record
of basically being pro-trump
and he's holding on to those coattails
and so i think it's an interesting
attack
your campaign has really focused on his
history he points out that he's never
been convicted
of a crime
listen i think he has a well-documented
long history of violence and fraud and
i felt that it was important for the
voters of congressional district 3
to know that you know whether it was the
waffle house i mean
he was basically ordered to attend an
anger management class
in response to that attack uh multiple
phone calls not just from his house here
but also
a separate instance is incidents down in
florida
of domestic violence and so i think
people
need to understand uh the type of
violence that
has been a pattern uh for dan rhodeimer
voters have been inundated with the
mailers the commercials
the attack ads how concerned are you
that this will be a tight race or that
he will win
listen this is a you know this seat was
drawn to be a traditionally
swing district it will be you know it
has always been a tight race in the seat
what i'm concerned about is i believe
that people want to have a congress
member
who has demonstrated not just by what
they've done
here in our community but has
demonstrated i have the experience of
showing
that i've been able to roll up my
sleeves and work with people of the
other party
i think that the divisiveness and the
dysfunction in this country
is so distressing especially right now
where people are on the brink
uh with respect to the economy wanting
people to work together
uh you know this dan rhodeimer his
slogan is i'm going to take a chair to
the back of washington he says that in
one breath
and then turns around in the next and
says but i'm going to work together
i don't know about you but traditionally
when i try to work with people i
actually
speak to them with respect instead of
threatening them
uh and so you know i believe that voters
are going to look at my 25-year track
record in our community
um you know from day one when i moved
here
i have gotten after the issues that are
facing us
whether it is homelessness uh you know i
started the city's first comprehensive
homeless
center when the school district cut
after school programs i started the
inner city games which is now the after
school all-stars
and then when we had our dropout problem
i rolled up my sleeves took over the
helm of communities and schools
which today is now the state's largest
and most effective dropout prevention
program
so i believe that voters are going to
look at that track record
they're going to look at my track record
in in dc
and they're going to understand that i'm
the type of leadership
that we need more of in washington i
juxtapose that to dan rhodeimer who is
basically clinging to the
the coattails of this president i
haven't really heard
a plan of what he has for the future
uh basically you know it's one thing to
say you don't like something
but it's another thing to get to work
and try to fix it and i've demonstrated
i have a track record of being able to
do that
donald trump did win cd3 by one point
in 2016. what about that concern and
have voters noticed enough of a change
um to vote democrat
listen um you know donald trump won it
by a point
i i was able to carry this district by
nine points uh
in 2018. um to me
this race is not about donald trump this
race to me
is about the people of southern nevada
i we are ground zero for the economic
devastation
of this pandemic we have a large and
vibrant
community we have a large community of
retirees who are worried about medicare
and social security we have you know
parents who are sending their you know
or teaching their children
online at home and i believe that it
will be a referendum
of not only who is going to help
us rebuild and you know my background
in our community of taking on the
toughest problems
i believe that i'm a member of the
education and labor committee
we have a we have a long path to
get out of this economic crisis but a
lot of it will
obviously go through workforce
development
making sure that we're bringing funds
into our community
to support retraining or training our
workforce
and i've already have a track record of
doing that nevada state college just
announced a two million dollar grant
that i
helped them secure uh to help with their
education
training programs uh especially
important because it's a hispanic
serving institution
and then i also was able to get a
million dollars for
area health education centers again
another
key workforce development program of
making sure we're training people
for jobs of tomorrow and so um
to me i believe that this race is about
someone who's willing to get out there
figure out how we're getting resources
into our state to help us rebuild
uh instead of someone who's going to
repeat
the divisive and violent rhetoric that
we have heard for the past four years
i think people are really tired of the
fear of the violence that we've seen and
they want to see
someone who's actually going to work
together and that's the key difference
uh in this race between myself and dan
rhodeimer
there were several debates on the table
but you did not agree to one
for now why not listen uh
dan rhodeimer had agreed to a pbs debate
um i agreed to it as well and then he
backed out basically
um and so you know it's on to him i
i agreed to a debate he had agreed to we
offered a debate though
huh we also and i had yes and i had said
because of uh basically
his health practices of having rallies
and
events with no mass that i was willing
to do one debate
i accepted the one debate that he had
accepted
and then he turned it down um
we've asked you about this before i'm
going to ask you again
for viewers who may not have seen those
previous interviews
there was controversy about your role
with ppp
loans and your husbands or your family's
business what do you want to say about
that
what happened uh well listen i
i think everyone remembers back in march
when we passed
the cares act the ppp program
one of the key things that was really an
administration
issue that had prevented gaming
companies companies that derived some of
their revenues from gaming
they were prevented from accessing the
key
small business program that was part of
the cares act
simply because they had gaming revenues
i along with
our entire bipartisan delegation not
just here in nevada
across the country many states who have
a large gaming presence
we lobbied to make sure that gaming was
included
in in the ppp program now i want to say
prior to that fix nevada ranked almost
near the bottom
in terms of the percentage of small
businesses that
benefited from the ppp program after
now we have seen close to 45 000
businesses
responsible for half a million jobs have
access to those critical funds i was
doing my job by advocating to make sure
that gaming was included in this program
along with
our entire delegation my husband's
company
i applied for it i had no decision in
their and them applying i had no deci i
had no role
in sba's decision of approving the loan
and i certainly won't have any role in
the repayment
of the loan uh you know they claim that
those funds went to support about 700
jobs
that's exactly what the program was
intended to do to support
employment and it was so important for
our state
uh and it was egregious that gaming was
cut
out of that program and i just did my
job by advocating for that
how concerned are you though that voters
may have heard about this or hear about
this and
think well maybe there is a conflict of
interest and
maybe she's just another politician
who's out for themselves how concerned
are you about that and what would you
say to them
i you know again i'd say that this was
an omission of the key industry
in our state and at a time when to
protect the lives of our fellow nevadans
of americans
we asked major businesses to completely
shut down and gaming was one of them
and it was my duty to make that fight to
make sure that
our main industry our main economy
driver
was covered by this key program um but
ultimately i think people need to look
at my track record
uh 25 years in this community you know i
say look at
what they have done and what the which
will
give you a good idea of what they're
about and what they're going to do
and you know from the minute i got here
i got to work
on key issues facing our most vulnerable
residents whether it was our homeless
community
our school children our kids who are at
risk of dropping out
and so you know i've demonstrated in my
career
that i've been able to get results and
roll up my sleeves and focus on the
issues that affect nevadans
and i think that's what people are going
to be thinking about
especially now as we're looking for who
are we going to have on our side
that's going to look past the political
uh rhetoric and dig in
and get to what we actually need to do
to rebuild our economy
and i think the choice is clear
congresswoman susie lee thank you so
much all right
thanks good talking to you have a good
one you too bye